you should know that if you are a
conservative in in any way in public
life if you're on the school board if
you show up to a meeting if you have a
protest if you have a sign in your yard
you could be subject to Serious violence
and the libs are not just joking around
and they don't just want to throw some
glitter on you and they don't just want
to egg your house they want to kill you
they want to blow you up they want to
kill you they're dead serious about this
there is a very Sinister aspect to
what's going on here this is not just
regular political fun and games okay and
I'm not saying that to discourage you
from being politically act quite the
opposite I'm telling you that we got to
be wise as serpents and innocent as
doves